nous sommes d'accord mon bon léonard
topola c'est ça monsieur du jeune homme
tout pour la partie et bien non non non
et non 1 que signifient ces cris de
protestation quelque chose ne te
convient pas ouais une seconde je
réfléchis si tous ne te convient pas
c'est que rien ne te convient cédera pas
grave mais en amour tu n'es pas d'accord
d'applaudir décision si j'ai bien
compris absolument pas tu es vraiment un
casimir us bizarre nous venons
simplement monsieur du synode et moi de
décider de faire une partie de dames
tous les jours je ne vois pas en quoi ça
te dérange évidemment vous ne pensez
jamais à moi me donne ne demandons qu'à
comprendre notre fou s'il y en a une à
la une pendant qu'il y en a une à
bonbons pour comptez-vous faire cette
partie de dames
ici
exactement c'est à dire chez moi et
quand se passe-t-il généralement durant
cette partie je ne vois pas as tu veux
faire allusion il veut faire allusion
aux éclats de voix à
chaque fois vous disputé toute la partie
mais tout ça n'est pas très grave
casimir enfin comment pas grave à mai
mais ce n'est pas tout et à quelle heure
comptez-vous faire cette partie de dames
ou que tu l'as entendu juste après le
déjeuner exactement et que se passe-t-il
après le déjeuner je ne vois pas et dont
je connais pas mal de devinettes
après le déjeuner j'aime bien faire ma
sieste tranquille voilà une excellente
nouvelle je n'ai rien compris à cette
devinette m'ont un peu mes enfants mes
amis réfléchissez un peu comment voulez
vous que je fasse ma sieste tranquille
si tous les jours après le déjeuner vous
faites une partie de dames en vous
disputant au mais fallait le dire que
nous allons nous arranger nous nous
allons changer d'heure quatre heures de
l'après midi ça te va quatre hommes en
quatre heures ce n'est pas possible le
j'aime bien prendre mon cloud by bull
gain de 4 heures tranquillement on va
boire alors disons
six heures 6 heures que vous le faites
exprès 6h et juste l'heure où j'adore
lire tranquillement avant le dîner 10
heures du matin 10 heures du matin mais
tu le fais exprès petit renard fait néo
bragarde sont bons pour ne pas m'aider à
faire le ménage monsieur du snob je
crois que tout est fichu oui je le crois
aussi mambo ronald ne font pas de partie
de dames c'était un bon réveil oui
j'ai réfléchi mes amis vous pourrez
faire toutes les parties de dames que
vous voulez et autant que vous voudrez
cannois qui par un
oui
le temps est venu pour moi de vivre une
autre vie de voir d'autres paysages de
nouvelles têtes ont ce n'est plus
possible je deviens désagréable ici vous
vous en rendez compte non je parle je
n'emporte rien je pars les mains dans
les poches
je te laisse ma maison léonard avec tout
ce qu'il ya dedans et vous monsieur du
snob prenez bien soin de mon ami leonard
ni les casses pieds mais il ne peut pas
vivre sans rien mais oui aux vaincus
casimir
je pars vivre une vie nouvelle à vers de
nouveaux horizons je vais connaître la
vie exaltante des grandes cités
mes amis
le départ ne soit pas trop triste
[Musique]
[Rires]
bonjour julie bonjour françois salut
quasi nul jean casimir casimir ça n'a
pas l'air d'être la grande forme
aujourd'hui
casimir à partir d'aujourd'hui mon vieux
il faut prendre une décision ah oui tu
ne dois plus manger qu'un kilo de
gloubiboulga par jour bon ça n'a
absolument rien à voir a alors tu va
ramasser des feuilles avec même les
elfes lutins
certainement pas les de quoi s'agit-il
alors
je n'ai pas le courage de vous le dire
mais aller chez moi
léonard et monsieur du snob vous
expliqueront tout mais pourquoi c'est eu
tant de mystère on en a insisté pas je
n'en dirai pas plus sain tu sais
françois tu m'inquiètes
allons voir leonard et monsieur des
snobs
vous êtes déjà là mais vous avez failli
rencontré julie et franche soir les
entrées vous croyez à ses sauts pour
arriver qu'on se sente encore là
maintenant
alors vous vous êtes manas
donc bien voilà je désire quitter lyon
enfants non non pas juste au moment où
je m'habitue à l'île aux enfants moi je
veux y rester mais moi je ne veux pas
partir avec vous moi peut nous vivrons
mieux un peu de pouvoir partir en
tournée sans accompagnateur merveilleuse
splendide etc sans dire le plus grand
après sérieux du monde moi albert
travail et qu'elle dure est la tour
n'ont pas arrêté de parler et écouter
mois un pain bon je ne veux pas partir
en tournée et je ne veux pas partir avec
vous je veux quitter l'île pour toujours
un
c'est très intéressant ça racontez moi
or c'est très simple
cette île est trop petit pour moi
maintenant je connais tous les habitants
toutes leurs manies tous les ballons de
françois se ressemblent tous les bonbons
de jurys ont le même goût non je veux
vivre une autre vie avec de nouveaux
paysages de nouvelles têtes je veux
partir pour toujours je ne vous dirais
qu'un mot bravo vous allez connaître la
ville avec sa foule c'est le billet pour
le faisait trop rui c'est vrai c'est
vraiment aussi beau que ça encore bien
plus beau racontez-moi racontez-moi
envie d'aller sur le ponton il voit
alors comment se sent
[Musique]
plus personne avec qui me disputer je
vais terriblement m'ennuyer coûte nous
n'avons pas été assez gentil avec lui
voilà tout mais nous julie mais ça n'a
rien à voir
quels signaux ne sont pas parce que les
limousines plus et parce qu'il a envie
de découvrir une autre façon de vivre
envie de découvrir de nouveaux horizons
pourtant on ne peut rêver depuis plus
agréable que celle que nous menons rice
si c'est vrai mais oui mais oui je ne
sais bien mais casimir comme beaucoup
d'autres gens d'ailleurs crois que ce
qu'il ne connaît pas et beaucoup plus
beau que ce qu'il connaît mais qui sait
peut-être que casimir loin de nous sera
beaucoup plus heureux et bien je ne suis
pas là encore il faut tenter quelque
chose pour la garder julien raison allez
trouver trouver une idée creusez vous un
peu tout ça va me dire à vos paroles
nous cherchons nous cherchons ça y est
j'ai trouvé une excellente idée je vais
lui chanter ma chanson excellent style
président stupide et pourquoi cela mais
rien raconte que tu veux connaître même
l'infini en vain ce n'est pas l'idéal
pour lui donner envie de rester ah non
alors je vais lui chanter la niaque j'ai
justement mis au point quelques pas de
danse taisez vous monsieur du snob votre
chance on ne parle que de vos voyages
salins sitrao d'autant plus à partir
allons mais alors qu'allons nous faire
il reste tâche en sont elles parlent de
lille on ne finira pas du tout lui julie
ta chanson est très joli mais elle est
un peu trop romantique mais non ne dites
pas n'importe quoi enfin la chanson de
julie conviendra très bien vous allez
voir ma chère julie jatta soir près de
moi et chante nous ta jolie chanson
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
avec beaucoup de couleurs
avec beaucoup de douceur
oui
[Musique]
kiwan et garçons
casimir chante à sa chanson
[Musique]
françois
une volée facile
[Musique]
je me réveille pas si je vais
bien je l'aurais mieux que si j'étais
[Musique]
le
non
on le classe que les poupées
oh
leur serine petites ombres et des grands
on
là un papy passer le temps
assis sur un banc j en
garde
meeting
[Musique]
on
mais je n'aurais même pas si je
[Musique]
mais j'aimerais mieux que si j'étais à
menton
[Musique]
ça
non
sommes pas plus avancés
évidemment vous êtes tous incapables
d'avoir une seule idée
puisque
tous les deux vous n'allez quand même
pas vous discutez en
juillet mois nous ne nous disputons
jamais oui il ya en attendant mes chers
amis il va falloir nous nous habituer à
l'absence de casimir
c'est promis
d'après match est ravie j'ai appris que
dans la vie où je voulais aller je
n'aurais pas pu faire pousser un grand
arbre ou dans ma maison mon côté
j'ai aussi un prix il m'aurait été
impossible d'avoir des lapins pour
voisin mais bien sûr casimir les lapins
ne peuvent pas créer leurs terriers dans
les trottoirs c'est exactement ce que
m'a dit monsieur
il faut vraiment être bête comme toi
pour ne pas savoir ça
qu'on ce qui m'aura et contrôler c'est
que les renards comme quoi non plus ne
peut pas creuser à un terrier tant mieux
pour eux si c'est pour tomber sur des
balourds comme toi espèce de 1 grâce du
pida
360 ou tu vas voir ta maman voté
pour le mille collines aux autres